Un año más La silla de myanmar estuvo
vacía en la apertura de la Cumbre del
asean los líderes militares Siguen sin
poder asistir a las reuniones
importantes de la organización y se
arriesgan a ser excluidos
definitivamente si no empiezan a aplicar
el plan de paz acordado en abril de 2021
dentro del bloque Indonesia ha sido una
de las principales buses pidiendo una
acción más dura contra la junta de
myanmark
Indonesia está profundamente
decepcionada la situación en mi armar
está empeorando no hay avances
significativos en la implementación del
consenso de los cinco puntos y luego no
hay compromiso de la junta no debemos
permitir que la situación en mi amar
defina a la Asia
mi hermana ha entrado en una espiral de
conflicto sangrientos desde que los
militares de rutaron el gobierno de
anson suquía en febrero de 2021 el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez condenó de nuevo la
escalada de violencia y la crisis en
materia de Derechos Humanos que vive el
país
los ataques indiscriminados contra la
población civil pueden constituir
crímenes de guerra según el derecho
internacional reitero mi llamamiento a
las autoridades de myanmar para que
liberen a todos los presos políticos y
pongan en marcha inmediatamente un
proceso para volver a la transición
democrática Este es el único camino
hacia la paz
las potencias occidentales han impuestos
sanciones a la junta mientras la
violencia sea intensificado en las
últimas semanas con mortíferos ataques
militares aéreos contra objetivos
civiles